[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue merci de nous
retrouver pour une autre saison
d'espèces autochtones en direct je
m'appelle anne-marie vent et j'ai décidé
de consacrer cette première émission aux
jeunes pourquoi parce qu'ils sont pas
encore à l'école ou presque en fait
c'est pas vrai rider italie colle
toujours leader quick n'a connu qu'une
douzaine de bonjour je m'appelle mots
qu'une équipe nationale du sc - heineken
oui mais mon attirail de côté nathalie
le psy lui placer mon animal d'esprit
puis je suis de kadeos pigeage wintz 15
bis très bonne présentation et tu as
quel âge je 18 et u à 18 ans et tu va
maintenant au collège dawson à montréal
donc tu es au cégep pour une deuxième
année c'est ma deuxième année
voilà et puis notre autre invité il
s'appelle hayden ouellette hayden tu as
12 ans et toi tu es originaire de quel
endroit de demain bien demain gore donc
equani cheat mois alors tu es en innu de
dd quoi nietzsche et ton père et
québécois et tu as mérité nous c'est ça
voilà ce qu'on avait envie de faire
aujourd'hui en fait c'est de parler à
des jeunes parce que vous êtes l'avenir
nous on va passer notre tour mais vous
un jour vous allez envahir la société
c'est vous qui allez prendre les
décisions c'est vous qui allez mener le
monde
alors ce que je voulais savoir c'est en
tant qu'autochtones comment avez vous
envie de mener le monde
brighton oui qu'est ce que j'aimerais
faire et c'est vraiment pour cela a
poussé les jeunes à poursuivre leurs
études
je trouve que c'est vraiment important
puis c'était quelque chose que ma
famille m'observe c'est juste peau est
fine et podcasts veut mais il aimerait
ce que je possède un musée dessus depuis
jamais seul truc c'est important puis je
vous avec les jeunes
et toi en plus tu es né dans une
communauté éloignée aussi un témoin des
grands centres donc il ya une difficulté
supplémentaire déjà de sortir de sa
communauté d'aller
dans les centres urbains pour aller
étudier comment ça s'est passé pour toi
pour moi c'était un gros changement
c'est sûr mais je me sers mon pas été à
l'école a meta fait qu'il visitait des
fois fait quand on a quand même vécu la
ville un petit peu mais quand j'ai
déménagé pourra venir à l'école je me
suis adapté un gros changement
alors on va en parler hayden toi tu es
même si tu es originaire en fait ta
famille est originaire d'equanil shit
domingue en toi tu vis déjà à montréal
depuis depuis toujours un dieu et tu dis
tu es en secondaire 1 maintenant ouais
tu vas à quelle école un jacques
rousseau l'école jacques-rousseau c'est
en longueur oui exactement
est ce que les gens savent que tu as des
origines autochtones est ce que pour toi
c'est important d'en parler de le dire
de montrer la fierté d'être autochtone
même plus quand je le camp une pose des
questions de voir ce que je viens je le
pense toujours du temps dit toujours que
je suis autochtone je viens de mingue
ans dans le nord est des affaires comme
ça oui oui en tant qu'autochtones
comment vois tu la société de demain
qu'est ce que toi tu aimerais y faire
pour qu'elle change et pour que les
autochtones et la place qui leur revient
moi ce que j'aimerais changer
premièrement c'est vraiment sous les
enquêtes des femmes autochtones qui
avance vraiment vraiment pas ah oui
c'est vrai qu'ils aillent j'aimerais
qu'ils avancent qu'il fasse quelque
chose pour les changer parce que c'est
vraiment des incas oui tu l'a suivi tu
as suivi tout tous les débats toutes les
rencontres non mais j'ai vraiment quand
j'en ai entendu parler ça j'ai vraiment
été franchie rider tu agite la tête toi
aussi c'est un dossier qui te sent
concerné par ce qui arrive aux femmes et
aux jeunes filles autochtones
oui c'est vraiment quelque chose qui me
choque ajoie seuil et rien qui se passe
puis c'est les femmes c'est sûr qu'ils
amènent des nouveaux autochtone c'est
dans le monde ce qui nous donne la vie
c'est important de les protéger etc on
parle de marteau s'est nettement chez
elle c'est elle qui nous donne tout
qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin pour survivre
même chose pour les femmes autochtones
oui oui hayden tu viens d'une famille
célèbre quand même mélissa mollen dû
puiser dedans
je suis fier d'être ton neveu oui j 109
oui et mélissa c'est une femme
extrêmement impliqué comme ta mère
d'ailleurs bérénice moulin du puits deux
femmes qui sont impliqués dans leur
communauté mais aussi dans la société en
général
mélissa qui hélas fogo la cofondatrice
d'haydn no more qui est un mouvement
très important où on donne la place aux
autochtones on les met à l'avant scène
qu'est ce qui te rend fier toit de
mélissa vraiment ça ça comment elles
expliquent deux pour les autochtones
cause qu'est ce qu'elle fait pour faire
le changement pour tous qui commet l
avance vraiment c'est vraiment un fier
d'elle est ce qu'un jour vous avez vous
même tous les deux envie de devenir des
leaders dans votre communauté
hayden se jamais été vraiment mon but
mais si je le pourrai je l'aimerais
troué et à ce moment là tu voudrais
changer quoi mais vraiment le j'aimerais
redonner la terre à l'aisance et de
désigner dans le grand nord donner plus
d espace 2 meilleurs afin de santé des
des idées donc ce soit et mieux pour eux
oui parce que la santé c'est important
tu en parles
et souvent c'est un enjeu important qui
doit s'en rendre compte trois d'ailleurs
à kitigan zibi rider les enjeux de santé
auprès des autochtones
on a beaucoup disaient depuis la demande
d'amm en effet que c'est important pour
moi mais aussi à la langue et la culture
c'est quelque chose dans ma communauté
qu'on voit pas trop souvent puis ce que
c'est quelque chose que j'aimerais
ramener à main comme nothomb à
parlons de la langue dessus tu t'es
présenter bon en disant que tu étais
anishnabe tu parles de l'algonquin en
fait tu parles anishnabe c'est important
pour toi d'expliquer quand même que
celle algonquin parce que c'était le
terme qu'on connaissait avant quand je
me présente à un échelon à belmont nikki
ça peut vraiment c ou fait que quand je
me présente algonquin chocolat alors
pour les gens qui nous écoutent qu'ils
ne savent pas c'est où
si tous itunes ou sur une carte
géographique kitigan zibi c'est
quelqu'un de vue c'est à peu près
deux en or ou s2 auto à 2h nord ouest
d'ottawa
donc c'est encore au québec mais c'est
presque à la frontière de l'ontario
parce que affrontera frontières
matériaux mais il ya beaucoup quelqu'un
diack qui tient lui à maniwaki du riz
sur ce tracé la voie
oui kitigan zibi est ce qu'on parle plus
en anglais comme seconde de singles
juste envoyé la france et c'est paul
meningaud
comment ça c'est toi tu parles si bien
français mais pareil vu qu'on habite à
québec puis on a habité à manioc agca
côté de manigod qui m'ont dit que
j'aurais besoin de fraîcheur dans mon
harnais kaki mort envoyées à nicolas en
anglais depuis la france elle est à la
maternelle
ok alors que la langue maternelle donc
la niche d'habitude par là la maison
avec eux et dans la communauté pop
vraiment dans la communauté les gens
puissent l'anglais ya boys
il ya des ja - puma soir qu'on parle
vraiment comme un conte seul couramment
qu'obama oui mais à part de ses alliés
les aînés ya quelques adultes mais quand
à ma communauté c'est vraiment l'anglais
c'est plus chez nous c'est juste là les
shabab c'est ce que c'est quelque chose
pourquoi tu veux te battre est-ce que tu
veux parce que c'est important c'est
l'année internationale des langues
autochtones
on veut sauvegarder c'est l'anglais y en
a certaines qui risque de disparaître
hélas comparable 60 70 langues au canada
l'oms autochtone plusieurs sont en voie
de disparition
ta langue à ce qu'elle est en voie de
disparition ouais c'est triste
ça me rend triste chez sema lankais a
disparu on n'en voit pas trop beaucoup
des jeunes en parler mais c'est quelque
chose que j'aimerais amener puis mamac
magra moyens me dit quelque chose que je
dois mentionner que nous autres les
autochtones on est tous pareils on
n'était pas pareil mais on a des choses
similaires mais quelque chose qui nous
donne une identité puis qui lui va comme
un gant tud différent des zones est
longue
oui c'est vraiment pour nous sommes oui
hayden line ou est-ce que tu le parlent
où est-ce que tu le comprends un peu
ben pas nécessairement fait non je le
comprends pas on complète seulement
vraiment coin où commencer oui c'est pas
évident non plus parce qu'on suivi dans
une famille métissée avec un père
québécois une mère et nous alors sapiens
des foires à mardi qu'elle regrette des
fois ne pas nous avons appris plus la
langue faut lui dire qu'il n'est jamais
trop tard il n'est jamais trop tard mais
toi tu es jeune tu pourrais aussi la
prendre yvette mullen qui donne des
cours ici à l'université de montréal des
cours dit nous est ce qu'un jour tu
aurais envie de t'approprier ta langue
d'origine
oui ça j'aimerais beaucoup choqué mais
soeur ils vont bientôt faire des cours
pour la prendre
enfin que louise au hockey il nous faut
pouvoir leur demander de t'apprendre un
peu ça important oui
alors quand vous vous décrivez auprès de
vos amis comme toi maintenant riders
étaient au collège dawson
est-ce que tu le dicter autochtone belge
aux pads est comme moi je serai deux
bassines demande chez kim et jeudi 7
octobre mais je dois pas me dire que je
parle à quelqu'un chez autochtone 10,6
me dominique assure que tout est cool
d'où je viens mais les origines oui on
dit que souvent les les jeunes en fait
les autos tonnes en général vivent de la
discrimination parce qu'on les voit on
les reconnaît bondia oui c'était un
autochtone est ce que tu as l'impression
que tu envie de la discrimination
députés en ville par exemple
depuis janvier non c'est plus un goût
différent des tristes effect avoir eu
des discussions mais c'est quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas pas trop beaucoup c'est là
c'est la france et on sait comment t'est
autochtone puis c'est commode c'est un
but il a dit igloo des tipis et les
choses dans mon compte elle dit avoir
déjà dit à l'école ma première quand
j'ai commencé l'année passée c'était
quand autochtone c'est ce que vous
habitez dans des tipis encore quand est
ce que tu fais pour les faire évoluer
dans leur réflexion la leur apprendre
qu'il ya autre chose des fois je leur
dis que non on habite à des maisons on
va à l'école comme tout le monde
europe et tout ça mais des fois sont
vraiment s'ils pensent qu'ils
connaissent tout moelleuse et où on
habite en collège et hippiques pour
aller à l'école je jugeais en canot que
ça se sait vraiment s'il pense oui on
essaie tout mais j'essaie de leur
apprendre le plus possible mais
évidemment des questions aux pieds sont
vraiment irrespectueux d'accord donc
ceux pour qui
vers qui a une ouverture tu peux leur
apprendre autre chose pour les autres tu
les laisses vivre quoi toi hidden est-ce
que ça arrive à l'école est-ce que les
gens se rendent compte des fois que tu
as des origines autochtones est ce que
un nom très peu juste vraiment mes amis
des fois ils me disent tu viens d'où je
leur dis mille l'origine mais eux ont un
peu plus de coûter de maturité acquise
et blues il savait qu'avec univers
social on en apprend tous exactement
c'est vrai d'ailleurs quand tu lis ton
livre d'histoire par exemple c'est la
même chose pour toi est ce que vous vous
rendez compte des fois des absurdités
qu'on peut trouver dans certains livres
ben moi pas vraiment vu que je ne
connais pas toutes les infos ici nous
faire des affaires que son vrai il faut
que je vous dise ça c'était pas vraiment
vrai melzer est ce que ça te fait réagir
des fois tu tout-va livres d'histoire
tunisie aie ça fait qu'acheter plus
jeune sam choquer mais le japon a comme
un contrôle et musées motion opitz et
ses impôts cela façon qui a pris à notre
histoire mais c'est la réalité aussi
subi mais profite même pas ça quand je
me dispute avec eux au fait que le jeu
est juste mais tu es dans mon coin
picoui par u2 qu'est ce que vous voulez
mais c'est la vérité moi je connais la
vérité puis c'est important pour moi
alors radio je disais à 18 ans hayden tu
n'a que 12 ans et déjà tu as fait partie
du parlement jeunesse est en fait c'est
un peu pour ça qu'on s'est adressé à toi
que je me suis intéressé à dos je me
suis dit waouh
un jeune qui a envie de parler qui est
capable de s'exprimer et tout raconte
moi ton expérience au parlement jeunesse
c'était il ya un an un an et demi en mai
2018 ne vois pas non c'est un fait non
c'est en 2019
ok donc c'était ici juste pour les gens
de 6e année
d'accord donc tu étais en 6e année quand
tu as participé au parlement jeunesse ça
sert à quoi raconte moi raconte nous ce
que c'est ben en fait c'est comme tu non
dits des projets de loi a maintenant
nous on avait le pour qu'on se rende à
l'âge des activités parascolaires et
pour la méditation dans les écoles mais
ça c'est pas des vrais projets c'est
juste une simulation pour faire moi
qu'on est comme des gens qui vont
démarrer une jolie hockey et ça tu l'as
fait donc toi tu te tue débattaient sur
quels projets particuliers sont le
parascolaire da comme des activités au
niveau à parascolaires alors si tu te
retrouvais un jour au parlement parce
que tu as dit que tu t'es intéressé à la
politique et que tu devais présenter un
projet de loi qui concerne les
autochtones se serait sur quoi me sens
vraiment selon les femmes autochtones
encore parce que ça je veux vraiment
m'impliquer pour parce que je suis déçu
d'avoir que les enquêtes avancent
vraiment mais vraiment pas mais
j'aimerais vraiment beaucoup qui avance
ça va changer d affaires si tu sais et
vous savez tous les deux qu'on sera en
élections bientôt elles seront
déclenchées au mois de septembre elles
auront lieu de 21 octobre évidemment il
va falloir écouter ce que les chefs qui
se présente on nous proposait est ce que
vous vous inquiétez pour l'instant c'est
le parti libéral qui est au pouvoir tout
est possible tout peut changer
est ce que vous craignez qu'il y ait une
régression selon le parti qui le
prochain party qui sera élu - est-ce que
ça vous inquiète
ben moi j'ai aucun problème moi parce
que moi même je suis jeune je suis coach
connaît patron tout ce qui en politique
j'aimerais politique mais je ne connais
pas vraiment mais vraiment beaucoup
d'affaires mais tu vas apprendre et à
plein temps pour apprendre devant toi
mais ce que ça peut vous inquiétez 3
riders si on change de gouvernement où
nous si on réunit le gouvernement
libéral est ce que tu t'inquiètes de des
efforts que vont faire que fera le
gouvernement le nouveau gouvernement en
place vis-à-vis les autochtones
ah oui pour moi même personnellement
c'est honteux par et pour moi il nous
dit qu'ils vont face et inuh promesses
mais ils font jamais un fake pour moi
c'est tenter de parer à mesure puis je
vais je pense pour qui aura beaucoup de
changements
là il ya un enjeu important on dit que
les autochtones ne votent pas ou très
peu aux élections toi tu as 18 ans ce
qui veut dire que ce sera sa première
élection à laquelle tu auras droit de
participer n'est ce pas vas tu aller
voter probablement pas il y en a pas
beaucoup qui avaient voté je l'appelle
maman n'avait jamais voté jusqu'à d'un
hip hop hop
les dernières élections tu sais quand
justin trudeau avait dit oh il y avait
fait beaucoup de promesses
puis elle avait de l'espoir oui puis à
l'éduquer moi je vais aller voter pour
la première fois oui il est allé voter
puis garde en cause qu'on ait pas de
changement il y avait ils nous avaient
promis beaucoup d'afro et puis il n'y a
pas gardé ses promesses faites moi je
vois pas ici mon vote va changer quelque
chose
alors qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
te faire changer d'idée et te dire faut
que tu ailles voter c'est important ta
voix est importante chaque voix est
importante
c'est un peu comme les scènes et les
dollars plus on a deux scènes plus on va
faire des dollars là ça faisait un peu
la même chose plus de gens vont voter
plus il ya des chances que on
s'intéresse à ce que tu demandes à ce
que tu exiges du gouvernement ça sera
pas facile c'est ce monsieur c'est une
habitude c'est ce qui grandit de ta vie
puis de soi peu de changements rapides
en flamand donati dit que ça va jamais
changer puis tu commences admettant et
je prends 2
- français sauf mon jeu surtout des
français mais surtout des femmes comme
enjeu c'est de protéger et puis je pense
pour tous est trop loin une pizza
guichard changé et puis je vais aller
voter
mais alors comment faire pour que les
choses changent si tu vas pas voter donc
si tu dis pas m
regardez moi je suis là et vous devez
m'écouter parce que c'est ça notre rôle
de citoyens aussi comment on peut faire
alors pour que les choses changent
c'est seul ça serait mieux d'avoir
quelqu'un qui dans les politiques qui
comprennent d'où l'on vient faire
quelqu'un d'heureux jeunes autochtones
ou quelqu'un qui a grandi sur une
réserve qui est d'aller d'aller d'aleppo
les deux cibles ils peuvent comprendre
d'où l'on vient puis comprennent que on
a des problèmes parce que je pense que
tout le monde il ya beaucoup de monde
dans les politiques puissent on peut
autochtones ou lyon pas d'origine
autochtone fait qu'ils peuvent pas
comprendre nos problèmes du dombief fixé
après 10,6 pour réseau de webcams un
compte que nous en tout cas on voit les
choses en un temps c'est un cercle
vicieux 1 parce que si on décide de ne
pas s'impliquer non plus on ne peut pas
faire changer les choses faut faire
entendre sa voix c'est pas évident il ya
il ya quand même des hommes politiques
aient eu roméo saganash entre autres qui
va quitter le parlement mais qui a été
là de nombreuses années il n'est pas le
seul ou si t'as pas eu l'impression que
ces voix là ont fait changer les choses
évoluer les choses que j'ai vues ce
j'avais eu mieux chagan h puis j'ai la
lotte lahoud femme je m'appelle plus
c'est quoi son nom mais ça me donne l
espoir d fiac et les hôtels opim il
battait pour nous un endroit oui oui toi
et tu donnes tu me l'a dit tu aimes la
politique est ce que un jour tu aimerais
par exemple présenté devenir député ce
que tu aimerais faire de la politique
ben c'est pas mon principal but merci
quand en grandissant j'aime beaucoup la
politique ben c'est sûr que j'irai
vraiment pour un député
oui fin des changements aussi alors si
tu aimes la politique
un jour tu auras envie d'aller voter bon
ben alors certes watts convaincre
d'aller voter
parce que exactement si oui si on aime
la politique c'est sûr qu'on va aller
voter puis on sait qu'il ya des enjeux
qui nous tiennent à coeur et qu'on veut
les défendre et pour changer une réalité
oui des fois c'est de faire entendre sa
parole de citoyens on a encore quelques
semaines riders pour pour travail est ce
que dans ta communauté la majorité des
gens ne votent pas aussi font la même
chose
je pense que je pense pas qu'ils aient
beaucoup de monde qui va dans ma
communauté moi je sais pas beaucoup je
ne peux pas être dans les politiques
j'aime pas trop ça mais jamais intéressé
fait que je parle pas trop d'être se
cache pas de mon âge m à ma connaissance
je pense pas qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
qu'ils votent oui oui on parlait du d'un
rôle de leader n'a vous êtes deux hommes
habituellement sur le plateau souvent je
reçois des femmes
je me demandais si c'était une
génération de femmes autochtones qui
étaient là pour défendre les droits des
autochtones
aujourd'hui a pas de femmes sur le
plateau est ce que les jeunes avec qui
vous parlez les jeunes autochtones des
femmes autochtones jeune fille est ce
qu'elles ont envie de s'impliquer dans
le monde autochtone pour faire changer
les choses toi ce que tu côtoies
beaucoup de jeunes filles de ton âge qui
sont autochtones
j'en ai laissé le fait que je connais
qui sont open c'est vraiment injuste
mais ça oui les autres abus vraiment
plus loin dans le nord oui c'est ça si
je trouve ça aura rencontré à montréal
oui c'est un peu triste mais étaient
cousines qui skie habitat equani che par
exemple est ce qu'elles ont envie elle
aussi de s'impliquer dans le monde
autochtone mais de là la famille plus
d'un or cela je les vois vraiment
rarement si c'est vraiment il est en été
où ce que les vacances on va les voir a
cité la mangue un peu près dans ce genre
d'endroit alors finalement t'es exemple
à toi c'est mélissa et c'est bérénice et
à maman mais c'est aussi mélissa est ce
que mélissa elle essaie dé foi d'autres
convaincre de dire et coûteux il va
falloir que tu t'impliques toi aussi
dans le monde autochtone faire évoluer
les choses est ce que ça lui arrive
ben un mot jamais convaincu parce
qu'elle sait que j'aime la politique
autochtone puis tout sauf un ne jamais
eu à convaincre a dit que tu commune
histoire de ton côté
est ce que tu en vois des jeunes femmes
qui ont envie de s'impliquer à kitigan
zibi ou ailleurs mais autochtone ouais
beaucoup jabob cook samara efira et puis
je fais mon devoir c'est y ait beaucoup
de jeunes filles qui qui veulent
poursuivre ce n'est pas tout dans les
politiques a dans leurs études
j'avais beaucoup puis même à l'école
jusqu'au top kunis femme autochtone puis
je sais pas qu'est ce qui est exactement
qui veulent fois mais je sais qu'ils
vont à l'école puis si je sais c'est
difficile de déménager de leur de leur
maison ou de la communauté pour nous ici
mais c'est ils font pas ce qu'ils
veulent aider leur communauté parce
qu'ils y poursuivre leurs études pour
faire pour aller chercher quelque chose
puis en à l'heure comme toi est-ce que
c'est ton but aussi de venir ici
chercher quelque chose à travers tes
études et de retourner un jour à kitigan
zibi way fait que quand j'étais à au
secondaire j'avais du talent je voulais
états prd et du mais là j'ai commencé à
regarder à médecine puis gt gt bon
escient ce jeune serveur se puis jetée
bon fait que le gia qui est peut-être
mal et doctor who pharmaciens fait que
quand je t'avais au cégep italien pio
nobs licenses j'ai fait une année lg pas
vraiment aimé ça mais je continue paris
harper mais déjà amené jeudi à mon père
que je sentais plus de la forêt ça parce
que lui aussi docteur fait que j'avais
un peu l'impression à cause que lui
docteur les jeux soient docteur mais le
gg parlé avec puis je me suis dit non je
suis pas vraiment quelque chose de
fâcheux l'épreuve du pied du vélo tu es
safir à l'épreuve d'éducation physique
oui il me dit je préfère né pas de
question parce que je suis docteur
bogies des docteurs dans les sphères
fait que moi ga je devenais preuves
début des discussions fusent et puis
retourner dans ma communauté j'aimerais
aller enseigner les jeunes puis je serai
là pour pousser à l'heure pour ce il
dans le registre très bonne décision
très bonne décision
hayden toi un de tes idoles autochtone
c'est le docteur stanley vollant qui est
médecin aussi est ce que c'est ce que tu
as envie de devenir médecin un jour dans
la vie
bâché que les derniers temps c'est un
peu un petit but que je voulais devenir
médecin aider les gens pour l'été les
sauver mais aurait pas beaucoup de
choses quand on est jeune c'est normal
il faut au contraire regardez tout ce
qui s'offre à nous dans la vie puis
aussi en tant que mélissa jamais aussi
cette année volant parce que lui il le
marché de 1000 kg mathy je me trompe pas
oui pour faire en sorte qu'ils les
autochtones soyez en santé qui il fait
un message pour que tout le monde soit
les autochtones 60 et plus j'aime ça
parce que la santé ça préoccupe beaucoup
partout oui on parlait de la santé on
parle de la santé physique on parle
aussi de la santé mentale une des
grandes un des grands défis à relever
pour les jeunes c'est de se dire j'ai
envie de vivre
j'ai envie de faire partie de la société
mais j'ai envie d'être heureux dans la
vie aussi parce que le taux de suicide
est encore élevé très élevé je sais pas
c'est quoi la situation à kitigan zibi
jusqu'à ce but on n'en voit pas beaucoup
de ceux ci mais c'est quelque chose
qu'on est en
on en parle beaucoup de puis on sait que
c'est plus c'est un problème majeur dans
les autorités pourquoi c'est pas un
manchot un problème majeur à kitigan
zibi parce qu'on a mis en place des jeux
c'est pas des différentes initiatives
qui permettent aux jeunes d'être
valorisés dans leur vie de tous les
jours je pense que notre communauté si
on a beaucoup de réseaux sont une école
on avait un sens de pour les jeunes oui
on ne
on a beaucoup de choses pour les jeunes
pour qu'ils se fassent puis en l'homme
coudre aide qui n'est pas isolé non plus
tueur on a d'autres villes puis d'autres
mondes on n'est pas une place très
isolés oui c'est ça vous n'êtes pas dans
des régions hyper éloigné donc il ya
toujours accès à différents services ou
et toi est-ce que hayden est ce que tu
l'a comprend la réalité des jeunes
autochtones qui se suicident qui n'ont
plus envie de vivre parce que justement
c'est tellement difficile mais moi j'ai
fait c'est récemment que je l'appris
pilot doit s'amorcer très c'est vrai oui
mais c'est ça pilonne faut faire des
changements aussi c'est j'avoue que ça
c'était aussi le changement qui qui font
consensus et des fois les quittent leurs
amis ils sont pas bien appeler issus ces
sociétés ils savent plus à qui en parler
ils sont un peu pris au dépourvu c'est
ça l'important c'est d'avoir un bon
réseau autour de soi et d'avoir des
services qui nous permette de pouvoir
parler de pouvoir exprimer son mal de
vivre oui maintenant parlons de choses
joyeuses
parlons de la culture autochtone parlant
des artistes autochtones kitigan zibi
est ce qu'il ya des artistes connus est
ce que tu connais des gens de chitiga
nous d'ailleurs qui sont tes idoles
mais ma mère marie suzanne hathaway ou
puisque nulle part saisine a tenu à
faire le business de traiteur à watts et
kerry puis à le fait des émissions avec
le chuv raivo v vient juste puis a
commencé avec de plus en plus connu puis
c'est vraiment quelqu'un que je regarde
ses allées et venues d'une petite
communauté
piet menaï il ya beaucoup de monde qui
la connaissent pas les efforts pour se
fixer à 2010 d'elle que je regarde et
vient de kitigan zibi la levée de la
crapule texte une wii aussi communauté
après une heure et demie mais non deux
qui tient de exactement alors lé cuisine
que ce mois là oui qu'est-ce qu'on mange
chez vous hommage beaucoup de bien ça va
aller
c'est mon traitement préféré puis on en
mange quoi va chasse et pêche puis on en
donne la famille puis on en gras pour
nous autres qui est sinon parmi les
artistes autochtones connu est ce que tu
as des gens qui est que tu suis que tu
aimes d'autres artistes de même
communauté j'en connais pas trop peu
différente à communauté mais de partout
au canada
ouais il y en a pas beaucoup de joie
quand même et je sais que je peux pas
t'aider dessus de leurs noms mais je
sais que j'ai les suivent depuis
j'essaye de
le camp de la plus de démontrer qu'il y
en a des artistes c'est on n'a nul
besoin d artillerie pour démonter notre
culture puis pour montrer aux postes
canada met au monde assez quand on est
encore ici exactement toi de ton côté
hayden est ce que tu connais certains
artistes autochtones et chanteur non pas
vraiment mais je suis quand même mieux
ma tante mini sow qui est une artiste en
quelque sorte elle écrit c'est une poète
est fait est là elle a participé au
wapikoni mobile aussi elle a fait
beaucoup de choses un cinéma pied aussi
ya aussi une rita j'ai oublié c'est quoi
son nom de famille mais est-ce que c'est
rita mestokosho mais ça je suis pause
lens je connais je pars rythme à gérer
ta veste au cochon c'est une grande
poète innu très connu aussi mais ça que
je te parle et elle écrit des livres
parce que ta ama gore avec nous mais
elle écrit des livres alors là moi j'ai
l'impression que tu me parles de risque
rita mestokosho on vérifiera sk vient
des couennes sheetrit tâche c'est plus
bas je suis fini je connais pas ses
origines
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'il faisait
des livres bd il était ce vraiment connu
ses livres est-ce que tu connais matthew
le chanteur matthew on va mettre ça sur
thalys de devoir cette année les couve
matthew est ce que tu connais scott ian
picard band
il va falloir t'y mettre ça serait
respectueux découvre le piano pic à ce
que tu connais florent vollant
ouais je catherine jacquot n'est
vraiment pas beaucoup les artistes parce
que tu as raison rider c'est important
les artistes aussi dans la communauté
c'est des gens aussi qui permettent de
comprendre les sociétés autochtones eux
mêmes sont des ambassadeurs de la
culture et du monde autochtone donc
cesser aussi wii est important de les
connaître
alors on va terminer cette émission dans
quelques instants mais avant de se
laisser chacun votre souhait à souhait
pour la société de demain la société
dans laquelle vous allez grandir
hayden moi j'aimerais beaucoup qu'il y
ait du changement
que s'améliorent la situation pour les
autochtones et qui récupèrent leurs
terres pour si les femmes autochtones
qui est soignée qui soyons bien sûr
c'est qu'on s'implique plus pour eux que
pour nous on s'implique plus dans la
société québécoise que les autochtones
moins que
qu'est-ce que tu donnerais comme conseil
à un autochtone pour s'intéresser aux
autochtones apprendre à les connaître
eux j'en sais vraiment pas trop mais moi
je dirais qu'ils devraient ils devraient
commencer par visiter le grand nord oui
les communautés hôtes on me donne aussi
un sans aller trop loin à aller faire un
tour avec wanted par exemple seraient
ils descendent la voie des musées qui
monte et les histoires des détecteurs à
leur place il ya d'autres endroits
donc là je suis concerné vraiment
d'aller labourer c'est un très bon
conseil
ryder toi de ton côté quels sont tes
espoirs pour l'avenir des autochtones au
canada et ailleurs dans le monde et
qu'il ya quelque chose que j'aimerais
vos maîtres l'éducation j'aime en europe
de plus en plus puis ça m'a vraiment
heureux mais j'aimerais avoir plus plus
de jeunes plus de docteurs qui poursuit
dans le rejet de ce puits qui continue
ce pour être médecin doctorat de
n'importe quelle sorte de docteurs
avocats des preuves professeur de
n'importe où des poches mais pas je sais
c'est profession de n'importe quelle
sorte de profession des mécaniciens des
choses en main on arrête besoins sont ce
pas important et aussi à plus d'artistes
comme en janvier justin pendanx un book
on en a besoin c'est quelque chose que
j'aimerais aussi voir ses plus de
culture pas juste dans ma communauté
martelé communautés impliquées dans nos
cultures nos traditions nos cérémonies
la langue mais je trouve que c'est c'est
difficile de faire les deux parce que
quand eto'o et quand précédente étude m
- au cégep faut vraiment je me concentre
son musée de cette fête
mais ma mon côté culturel faut se mettre
ça de côté oui je me concentre là dessus
mes chèques c'est impressionnant comme
deux vit maintenant dans notre vie d
comment je sais pas comment
c'est notre vie urbaine ou oui wind
urbaine de notre vie culturelle puis
c'est difficile de deviner les deux mais
c'est quelque chose que j'aimerais voir
quelque chose qui est je pense qu'il
serait possible dans le foot solutions
on a des projets puis on travaille
oui vous êtes de jeunes très particulier
c'était vraiment un plaisir de vous
recevoir et je les fais tout de suite
parce que je le disais vous et vous
recommencez l'école donc maintenant il y
aura pu moyen d'avoir des jeunes sur ce
plateau là alors merci beaucoup d'être
venus tous les deux aïe de noël est rail
d'un côté et puis bonne année scolaire
bonne chance dans vos études merci merci
merci à vous d'avoir été là encore une
fois cette semaine la semaine prochaine
on va s'intéresser à ces immigrants qui
s'intéresse aux autochtones et qui
travaille avec les autochtones pourquoi
pourquoi ils ont un intérêt particulier
nous aurons donc différents intervenants
sur ce plateau bonne semaine à vous à
bientôt
[Musique]